today we'll look at Cicero which is an
agent an AI agent created by meta AI
that can play the game of diplomacy now
diplomacy is a special game because
because it is a board game where you
need to communicate with the other
players in order to coordinate actions
and cooperate and also compete versus
these other players and this
coordination as I said is in natural
language than chat messages so any AI
agent has to actually communicate like a
human to the other humans at least if it
doesn't want to get noticed as an AI
agent here you can see an instance of
this board you can see there are these
different territories it's a bit
pixelish but I hope you can see they're
like territories and you can see you can
see the world subdivided into these
factions which each are represented in a
particular color so that would be all
the things all the territories belonging
to one give even player your goal is to
get as many as many territories as
possible specifically the ones that have
Supply Centers on them and your moves or
you have a bunch of moves available so
you can move troops around but you can
also attack other territories or you can
for example support a player that
attacks another territory and that's
where the chat comes in so in a regular
game down here somewhere there'll be a
chat window where you could chat with
the other players and you can coordinate
what you want to do what this other
player wants to do you can form
alliances and form a build up trust with
the other players and so on so this is
very challenging for an AI agent in
various ways we've seen board games
before like poker or chess but they're
always like just competitive between two
players not really Cooperative like this
one and obviously the chat message is
here they are a major part of this game
you have to keep in mind that all the
other players also communicate privately
with each other which is information
that you don't know So Meta has made
this agent called Cicero that plays this
game and places ranks about in the top
10 percent of all humans various in
various tournaments so this is pretty
cool today we're going to look at how
they built this agent how it works and
uh you know what what it does and what
it means so the paper is called human
level play in the game of diplomacy by
combining language models with strategic
reasoning as I said it's by a set of
authors at meta and it's a pretty
impressive system here in the abstract
it says sister integrates a language
model with planning and reinforcement
learning algorithms by inferring players
beliefs and intentions from its
conversations and generating a dialogue
in pursuit of its plans Caesar achieved
more than double the average score of
the human players and ranked in the top
10 percent of participants who played in
more than one game now again we're gonna
go through this paper but let me say
this ahead of time this works this agent
is good because humans are dumb like
humans are really really dumb that's my
conclusion from this I've read the paper
I've read the supplementary material
I've watched a YouTube video which I'll
link in the description by a
professional diplomacy player who
comments on a game that they played
versus Cicero like it's just one human
against six of these agents they've
commented that and my conclusion is that
okay I've I've it's over stated that
humans are are stupid but this game in
my opinion is first and foremost
interesting to humans because of the
human element because you can build up
trust as a human and which is a major
function of this diplomacy feature of
this chat feature there's certainly
want something to be said here about
coordination like the communication
allows you to coordinate with other
players certain actions but that's only
part of why this is important the other
part is as I said building up trust
chatter making people happy and so on
and the the fact that like a
professional like at the highest level
of diplomacy players still do that still
like build up trust and still say well
they say they say something like well
um here if if I were to do this to a
human the human would be like it would
be really be really flipped off and they
would be against me for the rest of the
game even if it's irrational but the bot
doesn't do it because it's a bot and to
me it's like well if the highest levels
of players succumb to things like tilt
and be being like aggressive and and
damped because you stabbed them in the
back ones which is the most logical
strategic move then it's kind of like I
feel the humans play this because of
that human element not necessarily I
feel
I feel in this game
um you could get away with with you know
throwing away a lot of the dialogue
except the coordination bit and you can
still you can just play optimally and
there's nothing that people can do I
thought for a long time you know what
game would I really want to see uh AI
play and my first instinct was something
like werewolf or I guess the modern form
is among us because they're also like
this negotiation and so on comes in but
again it hit me there well it's the
human element it's this human notion for
trusting someone which really has no
place in a game like this like in a game
theoretic setting building up something
like trust it means very little if you
don't play the game repeatedly over a
long time like if it has an end it
doesn't like means nothing the other
player can just betray you at any point
and if they're better off they want to
do that they would do it
um there's there's like imagine in chess
if if like if you like start trusting
your opponent or something like this no
um the highest levels they are ruthless
and I think Among Us would just become
super duper boring if you take the
humans out of it in any case I feel it's
still worth developing this this bot
here to interact with the humans because
capturing this human element is I guess
part of what this research is about and
not as much getting really good at
diplomacy because it it feels like the
field of diplomacy isn't that advanced
I'm not sure if I'm insulting any
diplomacy players right here but from
what I've seen the whole jittery
chattery trusty thing is is like it
seems like the game is very far away
from humans playing optimally
okay let's dive in so in diplomacy seven
players conduct private natural language
negotiations to coordinate their actions
in order to both cooperate and compete
with each other so that's the core of
the game Cicero this agent couples a
controllable dialogue model with a
strategic reasoning engine so the
Strategic reasoning engine here will be
responsible for deciding what moves
Cicero makes and the controllable
dialogue model will become will be
responsible for chatting with the other
people and here is an important thing to
notice and a little bit while I think
this research is really really really
cool and and
um I'm total fan of it but a criticism
of me is that these things are quite
disjoint
um and essentially essentially Cicero
relies on this thing here very heavily
on this strategic reasoning engine so it
plans its moves ahead which is kind of
sort of controlled by the dialogue it
gets but only a little bit it plans its
moves ahead
um and then it just communicates what it
wants to do to the other players using
this right here and because part of the
game is about coordination and
communication and also because humans
generally are seemed to be honest and
therefore this the agent being always
honest is also a good strategy or
happens to be a good strategy in any
case what the model doesn't consider is
strategically using language right it
just uses language it determines what it
wants to do and then it uses language to
like communicate that out
um but and then it there's some
filtering and so on but it never
considers the what it says as a part of
the strategy like it never thinks oh if
I say this to that person then you know
next turn they're gonna do that at least
not to the degree with which I would
have hoped and we're going to see that
but but keep keep that in mind also the
dialogue module as such is more like a
translator so they try to essentially
parse out what they call intents of the
game and then they simply use the
dialogue model to translate those
intents like you know troop one moves to
that country to translate that into like
hey my troops are going to move to that
country is that okay with you
um but it's it's not really part of the
strategy uh the language so that those
are a bit of the the disappointments
that I have right sorry right here but I
think think they also serve as the basis
for further research
so first of all they go into a little
bit
um
into a little bit of so background what
are the what are the challenges of human
AI cooperation in diplomacy they say in
games involving cooperation self-play
without human data is no longer
guaranteed to find a policy that
performs well with humans this is in
contrast to things like chess or go
where you can just have two agents right
have agent one and agent two and they
just play against each other all the
time and they will get better and better
and better and hopefully converge to a
really strong solution and under some
conditions and Optimal Solutions now
this is no longer guaranteed if you need
to cooperate especially what they say
right here a strategy that performs well
with humans right and that's the Crux
right here it's not necessarily about
finding the most optimal strategy even
as I understand it the most optimal
strategy against humans it's a performs
well with humans if you need to
cooperate although in this game I think
you could find like a really good
strategy absent of of much communication
yeah it says it may converge to a policy
that's incompatible with human norms and
expectations and that's the human
element that I mentioned these norms and
expectations I think that's what makes
these games interesting makes these
games fun to humans to sort of like
um you know is it is are they telling
the truth or they're lying or they
betray me how could they betray me
things like this it's that that's what
makes it fun right and I think that's
why people play play these games and you
know interest like that that's as I said
that's the exact aspect that's kind of
not modeled in the dialogue model right
here and in the Strategic aspect so
that's where a little bit of my my um
criticism would come from right here but
you know future research
um so here is a bunch of stats the
average the agent here
send and receives an average of 292
messages per game so this is a very
chatty game the chat is really a big
part of the game it's not as much the
moves it's like chat coordinate
negotiate
um small talk I guess maybe
so the challenges they say each message
the agent sends must be grounded if they
just had like some sort of language
model it would do whatever even if it's
trained on data of that game however you
have to have a way to control the
language model to say language model
please transmit this piece of
information right here to the other
player and we're going to see how they
train a language model that does it
they say
lastly diplomacy is a particularly
challenging domain because success
requires building trust with others in
an environment that encourages players
not to trust anyone each turn's actions
occur simultaneously after non-binding
private negotiations
again
it encourages players to not trust
anyone yet you need to build trust
that's the Crux I guess
so I've already explained the a game in
itself yeah one thing that I found
important was this ability that a unit
May support other units including those
of another player and I think that is
one of the mechanics that makes this
game you know include this aspect of
cooperation and coordination between
players so it might very well be that
players who do coordinate even if
they're technically enemies who do
coordinate for a move or two uh are
better off at the end than had they not
coordinated
there is a general overview over this
agent we're going to look at some parts
in more detail but this is essentially
it you have this board State and the
history over here this is quite your
standard input to a reinforcement
learning pipeline so the board state is
essentially what's happening right now
and the history is what was the move
before and before and before that and
sometimes that's actually relevant for
the game like in chess uh the history
plays a place it has an influence to
some degree like you can't make certain
moves twice
um in Atari games it has some degree of
relevance because if something flies
with some velocity you want the history
to estimate which direction it flies in
sometimes it's just kind of
helps the
um even if if this is markovian
sometimes it seems to help the
algorithms uh just because humans be
humans I guess and
it's not markovian after all but you can
think of that yourself in any case we
get the board State as an input
and that goes into different directions
as you can see so the first is this
planning module here the planning module
is very classic reinforcement learning
planning module so
we get we go from essentially from the
state
um we determine a policy for all the
players so that is that is what a
um such a planning module does you can
think of it a little bit like the Monte
Carlo tree search in Alpha zero or
something like this except now you don't
have two players you have many players
so what you want to do is you want to
determine a joint action which means all
the players move at the same time in
this game so so one action is going to
be what every player is doing and the
policy what the policies are essentially
the action distribution of all the
players
then you want to forward simulate that
into a future State and essentially
repeat that so you plan multiple steps
into the future and
um what you can also do is you can sort
of run an improvement algorithm to make
your policy better against all the other
policies and then these policies better
and so on so this is very classic I
would say not even reinforcement
learning this is just a very classic
sort of policy Computing uh algorithm
that you might know from from Game
Theory papers or something like this the
only interesting thing here or the novel
thing is that you do get an input from
um what's called here these anchor
policies the anchor policies are what
keeps the strategy in at a human level
and it's a bit tricky uh to explain just
here but essentially if you let the
model just do reinforcement learning
just do sort of computational planning
up here you quickly get into a state
that's what they explained above where
the actions become like non-human so
where the actions the the algorithm
thinks they're optimal but the human
would say like that's kind of weird no
human plays like this and I've
definitely seen sometimes this video
commentator uh say something like this
like that move is very bot like now
usually usually in something like chess
or so
um if you know Alpha zero is like 10
times as strong as the strongest human
and the bot does something weird then
you're like
I guess that's a really good move we
should learn what that move is about now
here it's a bit more tricky because the
it's it's a lot about you know this this
trust element this human element there
is a value to being more human
um even if that means that technically
you deviate from the most optimal
optimal action at least that's how the
authors see it and that's why they have
these anchor policies
so the anchor policies are Behavior
cloning uh policies so what you do is
you take a big data set I guess here in
big data set from from Human place and
you train a behavior cloning algorithm
Behavior cloning essentially means I
take one game out here is a state and an
action and the state and an action I
just observe past games how they went
and I just trained a model that if it's
given a certain state is trained to
perform the same actions as the humans
did in that game
um yeah this is sometimes phrased as
imitation learning sometimes phrased as
Behavior cloning has different names but
all about the same ideas and that policy
that they call an anchor policy because
it anchors the model to what a human
would do it's not necessarily the best
action but it's an action that a human
would do it's a little bit like a
discriminator in an adversarial model so
so they mix these two things they always
mix the anchor policy with the
reinforcement learned or with the
computed policy in order to get a model
that performs both well and like humans
um yeah and you can see right here the
anchor policies those are dialogue
conditional
so you can see that here dialogue
conditional because in this database you
obviously not only have the state as the
board was but you also have all the Chit
Chat that goes on inside of the state
right so you condition this Behavior
cloning policy you say okay here is how
the board looks here what the humans
have communicated what has the human
done and you try to clone that those are
your anchor policies interestingly
enough up here
you see in this cycle here
there is no notion of any of the
dialogue so all this planning here
happens without the dialogue whereas I
think at least we might yes all the
planning here happens without the
dialogue uh except the dialogue comes in
via the dialogue conditional action
model so from here the dialog comes into
this model and then that information
goes up here but that's a very very
indirect it's essentially the only
information that the planning has about
the action is
what would a human do in this situation
um given this board and this dialogue
this this board and this dialogue that's
the only information that you have about
the dialogue you don't have the input
dialog directly and your actions your
the actions that you do are not
including what dialogue you're gonna
send here you see only at the output of
this planning
module you have something that you call
intense so an intent is a sexual
essentially a plan to move somewhere so
the output of the planning module is
here the output action
what you do but before you do it or at
the same time before the turn is over
you can also communicate to the others
so you compute what you want to do based
on everything that's happening
and then you
determine these intents
so you say I think
um I'm gonna move my I'm gonna move my
troop from here to here and they are
gonna move their troop from here to here
and you can encode that as these intents
and as I said before what the language
model does is it
um
it takes these intents and it translates
them into chat messages so based on
these intents you now go and you
communicate with the other humans so you
can see right here the message model or
the message generation module here gets
three inputs the board State as well so
it knows what the board looks like then
the current dialogue like what currently
has been discussed so now it's the turn
of the agent to say something and from
up here it gets these intents so it
knows how does how do things look like
um what has the other person told me I
guess like what's the current status of
the chat and what do I want to do next
turn and what do I expect the other
people to do next turn and from that the
dialogue model then generates message
candidates which go through filters and
if they pass the filter they go into the
chat so the bot answers
so here you can see that the bot says
something like hi Italy care to work
together on this one if if you support
me there I think we'd both be able to
grow quickly Italy which is the human in
this turn says could you support me into
bull into Bulgaria in return so now
Austria takes everything into account
what it wants to do what it thinks Italy
wants to do based on what's been said
and so on and then it says
sure thing I have ordered sir to support
Greece or serbius to support Greece to
Bulgaria
and yeah
so that's how the whole thing works we
take in the current state
um we take in the current dialog from
that we compute
um two different things first of all we
compute these anchor policies right here
like what would humans be doing then we
with the help of that we also determine
a best action to take which is this
planning Loop right here once we have
the best action we uh generate these
intents from that that's just mechanical
what do I want to do what do the other
people want to do those are just the
policies essentially written out as
intents and from that we generate our
messaging our messages which are intent
conditioned and this happens in multiple
steps as at multiple planning Loops so
what I said before like the the dialogue
doesn't come into the planning it does
but as I said not in like a super direct
way the the agent cannot
decide to strategically tell some other
player something like the agent can only
decide on an action and then the
dialogue model is just responsible for
communicating that action to the other
players
right
the dialog model is a central thing here
it was trained to be controllable via
intents so what you want to do is you
want to have a dialogue model I have it
somewhere
right here
here
the dialogue
um a message is defined to have intent Z
if Z is the most likely set of actions
that the sender and recipient will take
for both the current turn and several
future turns
so that's how they determine the intent
during training so during training they
take a data set they obviously don't
know the plans of the people but they
take a data set and they annotate each
chat message with what they think is the
intent and
um that's this is how how they annotate
it
so they Define the intenders essentially
like the plan that results out of this
chat message
they say we developed techniques to
automatically annotate every message in
the training set with a set of actions
corresponding to the message content
during training the dialog model learned
the distribution this distribution where
Z represents the intent for data point X
and Y so X here is the input whatever
the dialog model gets as an input Z is
the intent like what the agent thinks
the plan of everyone is or what they
heuristically determined and then why is
the the output
here you can see some of these
um some examples
so in this case
um
the
the dialogue model
is tested for different intents so on
the top you see a situation
and
um a number of actions it's always the
same starting State you can hopefully
see that if you compare the pictures a
little bit but the actions are different
so the agent here is uh is England
and you can see for example this troop
here is I guess going here that's the
action that England takes or wants to
take
um over here it goes over here
and over here it also goes over here but
it even does does a bunch of other
things in turn and every time you can
see that the chat messages that the bot
sends now change so
um
I'm not a diplomacy player so all I know
is what they tell me so here they says
they say uh England convoys an army to
Belgium with the support of France and
Germany while taking Norway in a manner
friendly to Russia so we expect these
actions to be reflected in the chat
messages so to France it says would you
mind supporting this EDI to Belgium
so it sends since that is its intent to
move into Belgium it asks France hey
would you like to support me
if since wait
oh the Germans it also wants the German
support so they say do you want to
support my Convoy to Belgium with Italy
going aggressive France will fail
quickly and we can make gains of both
Russia and France so here you can see a
bit of an extended example of uh this
dialogue model now to me it's like a
tiny bit unclear where this comes from
because they said that intense cover
both this turn and turns in the future
so it's quite likely that some of what
the dialogue model here says is also
contained in the intent and it's kind of
like the dialogue model presents it it's
also somewhat likely that the dialogue
model just sort of makes makes stuff up
because it sees the board right the
dialogue model
um
right yes the dialogue model as far as I
yeah the dialog model sees the board
itself and it sees the current intent so
it's also quite likely the dialog model
has learned to just look at the board
and kind of talk to people about the
board State as such and I think that's
pretty cool like um it's not only it's
not only kind of mindless translating of
these simple intents it's not just like
I want your support there please attack
there please don't do this it the
conversation it has are surprisingly
Rich surprisingly uh sort of Flowery and
I'm actually surprised that this is
learned from Human data because as far
as I know online games like this must be
like the friendliest
online game I've ever seen people are
absolutely uh nice and polite to each
other
so it says how are you thinking Germany
is going to open I may have a shot at
Belgium but I need your help to get into
Denmark next year so again the intent
next year next turn or next uh
there's always like three seasons to a
turn to a year
um so it asks Russia for help in the
future at some point
so that's pretty cool and if you change
the actions that you want to do then the
chat messages change so a clear example
of how the chat messages are dependent
on what you want to do are controllable
and they also measure this and they find
that the quality of the chat messages
improves as well as rated by experts and
the sort of test perplexity on a test
data set improves once they classify the
intents behind the actions and not just
let like a language model run rampant
so here is how they train the dialogue
model the intent um control dialog model
step one is that they train this intent
model
so this is the model that takes a chat
message that it sees and spits out the
intents so it spits out what it thinks
the chat message wants to convey in
terms of like the basic moves of the
game
um this is only then used to annotate a
bigger data set we've seen this number
of times and this seems to be really
cool a nice strategy that you train an
intermediate model that then helps you
to annotate a bigger data set and if you
can get some very high quality data for
that intermediate model then you can
essentially create your own training
data on a much larger scale especially
in these RL papers this seems to be
quite a common
um a common thing and yeah it seems
worthy of imitation if you're ever in a
situation like this
so here we have a dialogue history from
a date set on the left hand side and
um you can see these chat messages right
here and the intent model it uh I think
it looks at the board State yeah and the
history of the chat
um and it is tasked with parsing out the
intent and it is trained on a a set of
what they call truthful situations
so they go through the data set and they
heuristically determine when are people
telling essentially the truth about what
they want to do and that's how they
train
um their intent model they train to
predict those things
that the intent model essentially takes
chat message and outputs well here is
what this chat message means in terms of
actions
then they go through the data set and
they use the intent model here
to annotate the whole data set as I said
go through the chats and they say well
England this was the chat message they
meant to convey this basic action
and through these intents
um the agent understands the game so
these language Parts here they almost
act like a translation pipeline between
the human world the natural language
world and something the agent can
understand namely this intent world
uh then they train this dialogue model
so the dialog model gets both the board
State and history and the dialogue
history
and the dialog model as I said
understands that this in terms of these
intents
and
once the dialog model is trained you can
then run inference
um
so you use all of this
to do planning from the planning you get
the intent and the intents go into the
dialogue model so during training you
get the intents from your annotated data
set and during inference you get the
intents from the actual planning
algorithm like the planning algorithm
tells you okay forget the chat history I
have determined also based on the chat
history of course but I have determined
that here are the the intents the
actions that people are probably going
to do and then it gives that to the
dialog model to handle these are
obviously a much better prediction of
what's actually uh what people are
actually planning to do then just the
chat history
foreign
they said we considered other Notions of
intent during development such as
controlling messages to focus on
specific subsets of actions third-party
actions or to have a particular tone but
I don't think they've included them
because it's very very hard so these
intents they essentially cover
sort of the direct what the player and
its its counterparties want to do out of
the game and not like oh say this in an
angry tone say this in a hopeful tone or
something like this that's for future
work
so going through this I think we um
we covered a lot of this thing already
um
yeah exactly so Cicero conditions its
Dialogue on the action that it intends
to play for the current turn uh this
Choice maximizes Cicero's honesty and
its ability to coordinate
and they say it sometimes led to out of
distribution intense when the intent
intended action was hostile so since
sister is always like honest because
it's trained on this kind of truthful
subset and it just it just communicates
its intense so sometimes it just tells
humans like I'm going to attack you
where a real human would like either lie
or just say nothing at all because
hostile being hostile but the bot has no
the bot has no like notion of oh this is
not socially appropriate so it just
knows I need to communicate my intents
which I I find quite funny I think
um
so here is an evaluation if you
just use a language model
um and you look at dialogue quality and
perplexity in the data set you improve
quite a lot if you also ground it in the
game State and you improve then again if
you ground it in these predicted or
annotated
intents and that's what this model does
right here
so now we go through the Strategic
reasoning part as I said this is more
like the classic uh classic planning
algorithm rather than something very
novel and also doesn't rely on the
natural language as much as you would I
guess I would have hoped so
says Caesar runs a strategic reasoning
module that predicts other players
policies and also its own I guess for
the current turn based on the state of
the board and the shared dialogue and
then chooses a policy for itself for the
current turn that responds optimally to
the other player's predicted policy so
the input to this as I said is the state
of the board and the shared dialog
but the output action is just like
policy and the policy is just the
distribution of actions what I would
want to see is that the policy also
includes language actions so here
actions in the in the policy it's purely
like oopsie sorry
it's purely uh you know what you saw
before like I want to go from Belgium to
whatever other place but I would really
love to see that the action set here
gets extended by something like uh tell
Russia
to go to somewhere right that right now
this is just a consequence of the action
I select and the language model is just
tasked with communicating this but if
this here was an action too then my
planning module could actually reason
about what it would be best to
communicate and to whom in order to
achieve my goals and I think that would
make it much more interesting obviously
also much harder but also much more
interesting
um
foreign
yeah so here they go into uh saying it
requires predicting how humans will play
uh Behavior cloning is a choice however
pure behavioral cloning is brittle
especially since supervised model May
learn spurious correlations
so they have a variant of pikl it's an
iterative algorithm that predicts
policies by assuming each player seeks
to maximize the expected value of their
policy and minimize the KL Divergence
between that policy and the behavior
cloning policy which we call the anchor
policy so again they want to maximize
their reward
by simply being a cold-hearted bot and
they also want to stay close to what a
human would do in order to fit in with
the humans who actually play a
Cooperative game with the humans
they go a little bit into that here you
can see that clearly here is the
essentially utility of a policy and here
is the KL Divergence between your policy
and the anchor policy and there is a
trade-off parameter called Lambda that
controls how much of which there is
interestingly
interestingly at some and I think that's
later and I have it marked somewhere but
I'm gonna say it now otherwise I'll
forget it once they do the actual
inference they tone down this Lambda
um quite a bit
um so they use this in in two different
settings once to like annotate and infer
things and then once they select their
own action they tone down this Lambda
quite a bit so essentially they're
saying like yeah we want to be like the
humans but then you know we really want
to win and I think that's what results
in some of these like bot like moves
that the commentator uh commented and it
tells me already again a little bit that
the humans who are playing this game
probably aren't playing it very
optimally otherwise uh it would not be
that much necessary to
um to have this Lambda up it wants you
to have this Lambda very high when you
infer the human actions but have it much
lower sorry this hand to have it much
lower when uh the when when you
determine your own action because you
want to win the game essentially means
that the humans could also play a bit
more optimal and win the game a bit more
often
um yeah so
we went we went from we went from how
can we control the dialogue via the
actions we plan and now we see the other
way around dialogue conditional planning
oops that's out of your reach
how does the dialogue that happened
affect the planning I do I before I said
it doesn't much but it does in in this
indirect way uh but nevertheless the
dialogue very much affects uh what the
bot wants to do or does
so here
um the bot is France a blue player and
the opponent here is England the chat
partner that it chats currently with is
England and here you can see if one
message if england says yes I will move
out of England if you head back to Nao
then uh the text here says Cicero
predicts England will Retreat from Eng
to nth 85 of the time backs off its own
Fleet to Nao as agreed and begins to
move armies away from the coast however
if england says something like you've
been fighting me all game Sorry I can't
trust that you won't stop me and then
the actions change Cicero does not back
off its Fleet but rather attacks EDI
with it and leaves its armies at the
coast to defend against an attack from
England predicting that England will
attack about 90 percent of the time and
that's just based on the dialogue right
so you can I almost apologize a little
bit because I think I feel at the
beginning I have
um sort of understated the importance
but
you can see how this comes in here so
you have two policies that you determine
one is just planning the other one is
this Behavior cloning policy which is
dialogue conditioned so in this case the
system looks at this chat message versus
this chat messages and it determines in
this Behavior cloning policy what would
a human do that has sent me this chat
message and that that goes into this
strategic planning module on the other
hand it determines what would the human
do that has said this thing right here
and that goes into the strategic
planning module so the bot adjusts its
own action
by understanding how humans would behave
when they have uh sent a certain chat
message
again this is the this is as far as I
understand it the result of the behavior
cloning training and not the strategic
planning itself so the strategic
planning isn't gonna be like well they
said this but are they saying it because
they want to convince me of something
and therefore I should do this and that
right it's not that it's just like oh a
human that says this probably uh attacks
me 90 like a bunch of times right so I'm
gonna adjust my the policy because of
this part because of this part right
here
um because this part here is still kind
of the same
so
that's what they say right here Cicero
does not explicitly predict whether a
message is deceptive or not but rather
replies on Pi kl to directly predict the
policies of other players
and yeah that being said the policy of
other players isn't just a result from
the behavior cloning
um the policy of the other players is
also determined via the strategic
planning model it's just that the
information
about the dialogue that goes into the
strategic planning comes from comes
through the behavior cloning part
so they go into a little bit of modeling
here you get obviously a lot of uh cases
where you need to I want to almost say
improvise a little bit for example you
don't have the private conversations
between the other players yet still you
have to model it somehow right
um
so uh it's it at various points they use
various methods to sort of infer the
strategies of the different players they
do that iteratively they say during
strategic planning for each player
Cicero computes an anchor policy for
both itself and the player based on
their shared conversation the board
State and the recent action history
Cicero then ran
d-i-l-p-i-cal which is uh their variant
of pikl that not only includes two
players but I think is that the variant
I think so I think I'm describing the
right thing here oh no
d-i-l-p-i-cal for the two players is
that distributional okay for the two
players in order to predict player J's
policy on each iteration Cicero assumed
the five remaining player will play
according to a policy computed via RL
so since you don't have the dialogue you
don't have the behavior cloning policy
because that relies on the dialogue
therefore you need to compute some
policy via reinforcement learning to
just approximate a policy
conditional on the policy of system
player J this process gave an
independent prediction of each player's
policy next Cicero accounted for the
fact that the player's policies were not
independent due to their ability to
correlate their actions with private
dialogue so they adjust it
um
by the likelihood ratio of a under the
correlated and independent RL policies
so there's a lot of adjustment happening
for the fact they don't have all the
information you'll find this commonly in
RL algorithms that where there's some
hidden information and even in somewhere
there isn't hidden information
but that don't sample uniformly
it's a bit of a same concept and
finally Cicero chose or chooses the
action that best responds to the
predicted joint policy of all the other
players the minus I here means the iath
player isn't meant
while still being as consistent as
possible with its dialogue
and here is what I said
um
sister uses a smaller Lambda for
regularizing its best response than for
its computation of the other players
policies it's kind of like
yeah I want to be like a human but I
really I really want to win
so this they say this allows Israel more
leeway to deviate when the action he
predicted humans would most likely
choose in its situation was sub-optimal
which I guess tends to be quite or at
least sometimes
um
yeah so then they go into how they use
self-play reinforcement learning in that
so they run this in an iterative fashion
they not only do it once so they run it
in iterative fashion they compute
optimal policies and go around do it
again again and so on
um I don't want to go too much into that
if you want to read it
it's a it's a short paragraph and
it has a bit of a supplementary so the
supplementary material is quite huge so
Props for releasing a lot of that
lastly they have this paragraph on
message filtering which is a last step
where they boost the the performance and
the
um way the quality rated by experts of
these models Again by quite a lot
they say neural language models suffer
from contradictions inconsistencies as
well as a tendency to hallucinate or to
generate factually incorrect information
they say their model obviously does the
same deviates from the intent and use
that used to control the message it
blunders in the Strategic content of the
message we approach this problem by
filtering generated message using a
series of classifiers and checks to
detect common issues
as this essentially post-processing of
their message model so they sample and
if it doesn't pass the filters I guess
they just sample again
by the way are these are these here
intended these references I'm not
exactly sure
in any case
they say discriminating between human
text and counter factuals so here we go
into the question well how can we filter
out kind of garbage if the data set that
we have is all generated by humans and
therefore we have to assume that it's at
least somewhat sensible
um so you just create your own garbage
they say we generated many kinds of
counterfactual messages that contain
mistakes language models are prone to
including heuristically corrupted text
as well as model generated negatives we
trained a suite of 16 classifiers to
discriminate between the ground truth
human message and different kinds of
counterfactual messages so essentially
just train classifiers that can
differentiate their created garbage from
regular human messages and they hope
that they have gotten close enough to
the common mistakes that language models
make and also that they've captured
enough of those mistakes in their
heuristics such that the classifiers
will get will generalize essentially
and just it generally filter out most
non-human text
the this is um also interesting they say
we filtered messages that would reduce
the likelihood of the actions in the
intent
um
yeah so they can determine from the
message they would send like uh what can
we classify the intent because they have
the model that takes a chat message
um
and then classifies the intent or even
they can take that chat message and feed
it back into their planning algorithm
and essentially say well does that does
that does that make it more or less
likely that I'm going to do the actions
that I want to communicate if it makes
it less likely they determine probably
it's not saying what I wanted to say and
they throw it away again their their
goal or their their design here is such
that the language model is like
extremely honest about what it wants to
do and they counter it with this next
thing this is the only place where they
sort of like
where they counter this tendency to be
like this super duper honest
and they say conditioning on intents can
lead to information leakage where an
agent reveals compromising information
about its plan to an adversary
to mitigate this we developed a method
to score potential messages based on
their estimated value impact we computed
the pikl policies for all agents after
each candidate message and filter those
that led to lower expected value for
Cicero playing its intended action so I
didn't discuss this explicitly but they
have a value function
um and the value computation method so
they run this planning algorithm forward
they can see into the future and they
can determine the value of the game for
the player much like Alpha zero or
alphco or something like this and
now they take the chat message that they
want to send and they determine is this
even good for me down the road if I send
this message and if it turns out it's
probably not that good for me if I send
this message then they don't send it so
that's a little bit of a counter to just
being fully open and just communicating
whatever you're gonna do to everyone
which is not always the best thing in
this game
so they have a bunch of other filters
they say here if you want to check them
out they're in the supplementary
material
and last thing they say is how they
participated in human play so they
played a bunch of online tournaments
without telling the humans that it's a
bot
and I found this I found this quite
interesting
uh the website notifies users that the
website has participated in AI research
and that certain game modes allow users
to play with AI agents
but in these games the humans were not
explicitly informed that they were
playing with an AI agent for that
particular game Cicero's participation
as an AI was revealed to all players
after the conclusion of the research
I've seen actually a message by one of
these players and that person was
completely flabbergasted they were like
I got the email and I'm like what that
was an AI no way I like so the the model
is quite good but I I can't help but
notice that that this is an experiment
on human subjects and really really
needed to go through an Ethics review
board and I was under the impression
that it's extremely terrible to let
people interact with a bot and not tell
them with every message explicit
basically that it is a bot and
um I don't want to draw false
equivalences here this is very cool
research and in no way do I think anyone
was in danger by not knowing that this
was a bot so that was the the paper they
have a bit of a discussion down here and
a bit of more examples so here they have
a bunch of successful dialogue examples
on the left where they coordinate so
Cicero is Austria Italy Italy says
something like what are you thinking
long term should I go for turkey or Head
West and you can see just I mean if you
read this dialogue oh sorry if you read
this dialogue you can see how like it's
it's not just like blah I communicate
the intent very plainly but it really
reacts to the other players it really
talks about them about also longer term
strategy it refers to States things that
are on the board correctly it refers to
its plans a few turns in ahead correctly
and so on so here Italy or Austria
says something it convinces Italy to go
to I don't know turkey or or beat turkey
Italy says I'm down to go for it would
you would definitely need your help in
supporting me and Oster says of course
happy to do that fantastic
on the other hand here's an example of
negotiation uh France is Cicero France
says I'll work with you but I need Tunis
for now turkey says Nope you gotta let
me have it and Frank says no I need it
you have Serbia and Rome to take uh
they're impossible targets and then
France suggests a series of moves and
turkey says hmm you're right good ideas
so I'm again I'm I'm not I'm not sure
that the humans here
um maybe that particular human I'm not
I'm not sure I I've never played this
game so I can't tell if this is actually
something that that happens at a high
level of Play Still that someone
suggests a series of moves to you and
you're like oh yeah that that is a good
idea I'm pretty sure like really good
players consider uh all of the things
already but
um yeah
in any case I I think I still think it's
like really really cool research
um
here they say although sister is shown
to be effective at cooperating with
humans it occasionally sends messages
that contain grounding errors
contradicted its plans or otherwise
strategically subpar but they say well
essentially humans occasionally make
similar mistakes which is probably an
understatement like humans are chaotic
and and dumb and sister is probably like
the most honest the most like consistent
player in the entire world at this game
from a strategic perspective sister a
reasoned about dialogue purely in terms
of players actions for the current turn
it did not model how its dialogue might
affect the relationship with other
players over the long-term course of a
game considering this might allow it to
deploy dialogue more strategically the
expressive power of our intent
representation limited Cicero's ability
to control richer affordances of
dialogues such as strategically
revealing information asking questions
or providing explanations for its
actions and that is exactly the the kind
of thing I said at the start it's a
really cool research to show that you
can actually pair language models with
these things and and interact with
humans in this way however the language
models here they more in they more act
as like a translation engine between
just what the planning spits out or what
the planning needs as an input
rather than as sort of actions to be
taken by itself and I would really see
the continuation of this work where the
model also considers kind of like its
own dialogue as actions that's not going
to be it's not going to be super uh easy
I want to guess to to do that
um especially also because yeah as my
suspicion is still that humans here are
far from the optimal strategy and
therefore the whole balance between
Behavior cloning and training on this
human data set and actually making moves
might be quite far apart and I'm not
sure how to reconcile that best it might
also be that the humans through this
botcom to learn that actually there's
probably better strategies around which
has happened in like go and chess and
poker so far so I'm excited to see what
the future brings definitely recommend
to check out the YouTube video by the
commentator has a lot of gems in there
and a lot of things where you can kind
of see the effects that the bot training
has had it they also say well yeah the
bot is quite honest for one and also the
bot is quite like non-emotional so even
if you stab it in the back it would be
like not mad at you it would still be
completely rational and things like this
and to me that's it's it um it's very
cool to see that even in such a game the
human element seems to be sort of the
primary uh fun maker even at a high
level of play and yeah I I think that's
that's I think the the best message we
get out of this research all right I
hope you enjoyed this paper review uh
wish you a very pleasant evening and
I'll see you around bye